so doctor
it's that time again
[Music]
oh how these announcements just throw
off all the plans i have for what i'm
gonna do with my day
but uh i can't leave this i can't even
like bump what i was planning to do on
saturday
this has to happen right now this talk
it has been officially announced and
confirmed by the bbc
that both chris chibnall and jody
whitaker
will be departing doctor who
not right away so there's a lot of
details go
to go over and there's a couple of
things that i want to be sure to
emphasize because i know that there's a
lot of things that are gonna get
uh twisted by some elements of the
fandom
out there a lot of them are gonna be
shouting see we were right they were
leaving after series 13.
uh well first of all you saying people
said they would be fired after series 12
or whatever but you know
you keep pushing it back eventually yes
they will leave and you'll be
right but they're not leaving right
after series 13 which
airs later this year there are going to
be three specials in 2022
and that will close out jody whitaker so
in terms of her time as the doctor
it's actually mirroring david tennant
more than anybody else who did
three series proper and then his
specials he did four she's getting three
now granted there's some other weirdness
because uh jody's series have been
shorter than tenants were but that was
something that i suspect would have
happened regardless of who was in charge
and plus we've had covet in the mix and
it's like it's been weird
but that appears to be where they're
sort of mirroring things
off of now as far as both
chibnall and whitaker leading at the
same time for whitaker
it's actually not that different from
the last few doctors i mean tenant got
more specials than the other basically
got a
series of specials but it actually seems
to become pretty standard for the actors
playing doctor who
three series close out with a special or
two
in the case of matt smith or before in
the case of david 10 i guess it really
was only capability who only had the one
special
after his last proper series but in any
case this
is actually fairly typical and if you've
been following the patterns for how
long these actors stay in the role of of
the doctor
whitaker's time it actually fits it fits
completely cleanly in what the pattern
has been uh with the only major
exception of the modern era being
eccleston
who left after only one series for
reasons i'm not going to get into
right now but the steady pattern is
holding right now three series special
of
anywhere from one to four and then
you're done so
chipmuna leaving this quickly that is a
little bit more
atypical this will make him the shortest
tenured
showrunner for the modern era of doctor
who
now no doubt some out there in the
fandom will be saying that
it's because he was terrible he was
fired they asked him to leave
he or he fled because no one was liking
his ideas like
look while i will concede all of that is
possible
none of it is confirmed that it's not
necessarily true for what we know right
now it is
equally plausible that he just only ever
planned to do this and that's what he's
currently saying
what he is currently saying is that both
he and jody whitaker went
into this the plan is three years and
then done now turns out three years on a
little extra with the specials but yeah
three years
and done and i did double check this
because that kind of rang a bell and
they're like
wasn't there supposed to be a five-year
plan i went back and checked to those
original news articles and
there's something that i noticed there
that i had never noticed before although
it was
claimed when chibnall shortly after he
was first announced as the new
showrunner that he had a five-year plan
he himself never made that claim nor did
anybody
working in the bbc directly with doctor
who the person who said
that was james strong who is a friend of
chibnalls and was a collaborator and a
director on broadchurch
so he was taken as a reliable source but
chidnal himself never said he had a
five-year plan that i was able to find
so i don't really have a reason to
doubt him when he says this was always
his plan
to come in with a three-year timeline
and scheme
and to close that out and then move on
to other things now
again i will grant it's possible that's
not true and it's certainly true that
it's fairly standard industry practice
that
unless it is impossible to claim that
something was planned all along
that's generally what you're going to
want to do even if something has gone
off the rails
it's standard policy within the industry
and not just the bbc hollywood
film and entertainment making in general
to claim that the way things are going
is the way it was always planned to go
don't admit it's gone off the rails
unless there's no conceivable way you
can hide the fact that it's gone off the
rails like
what happened with things like the dc uh
film series
so short of that level of sorts of
things they're always going to claim
this was always the plan we may find out
at a later date that wasn't
really true but for the information we
have right now
i don't have a reason to doubt him
beyond the taking with a grain of salt
basically anyone who says oh yeah that's
that's always what we were gonna do
maybe maybe not it doesn't really matter
too much at this point
it is worth kind of bringing up uh the
questions of
when are we gonna get announcements for
next show runners
and next doctor now we can expect
announcement for next show runner to
happen
first because whoever the next show
runner ends up being
is going to decide who the next doctor
is
so that is um kind of a big
factor and what we should be looking out
for first and
it's going to be difficult to nail down
timeline in all of this
but i did take a look at the pattern of
how things went
with from tenant onward because again
ecclestone
circumstances were different but since
then there's been a pretty consistent
pattern in if not the amount of time
that passes between
announcement of leaving an announcement
of next doctor or what have you
there has been a consistent pattern in
the order of events
so starting with david tennant july 2008
marked the end of series four his last
full series
he announced in october of 2008 that he
would be leaving the part
january 2009 matt smith is announced as
the replacement
tenant's final episode is january 2010.
jumping to the end of smith's tenure
his last series series seven finishes up
in may of 2013.
he announces his departure in june of
that same year
capaldi is announced to succeed him in
august of 2013 so again within the same
year
and then smith wraps up his time with
this final episode
in december of 2013. capaldi is a little
bit of an outlier because he actually
announced his departure
ahead of his final series which wasn't
the case with the other two
he announced his departure in january of
2017.
series 10 wraps up in july of 2017.
later that same month jody whitaker has
announced
as the new doctor with chris chibnall
having been confirmed as the showrunner
a couple of months before
and then capaldi closed out his last
episode
in december 2017. so the general pattern
has been
with capaldi accepting it slightly has
been usually
in terms of these announcements finish
whatever your last series is going to be
announce your departure announce the
next doctor
actually close out your run with
whatever specials it's going to happen
with
now we've already broken from this
slightly in that this time the
announcement is happening
ahead of the airing of her last season
now again that is not consistent with
smith and tenant but it is consistent
with capaldi that is also what happened
with him after series 10 had been
shot he did confirm this
is my last one and then it started
airing and that is
what we're looking at right now with
whitaker series
13 has been shot we're starting to get
promotion for it
but before it airs she is announcing her
departure
i still even though this is this with
her and capaldi is slightly different
what has been consistent is next doctor
does not get announced until after the
final
series proper for the outgoing doctor
so smith was not announced until after
series four
finished capaldi was not announced until
after series seven was finished
whitaker was announced within the same
month but after
series 10 was finished so that is
something that
look the speculation is going to start
really ramping up it's been happening
anyways because
uh well some people because they just
didn't like run the part some people
because of
pattern recognition three series maybe
we should start guessing who's gonna be
next
but like it's really gonna ramp up now
that it's official now the question of
show runner that to me right now is the
much
more key question than the question of
who plays the part next because it's
it's
kind of been strange with chipnel and
whitaker
conversations about their tenure have
linked them together a lot more tightly
than i think is has been standard up to
this point and what i mean by that is
i don't really see too many people
i think honestly myself included who are
able to talk about whitaker without
bringing up chibnall or chimney
without bringing up whitaker and that
might not seem strange because like
he's writing for her she's portraying
his words why wouldn't you link them
together
their tenures are gonna be exactly the
same too well here's the thing i've had
the conversation with a lot of people
about say peter capaldi and i've had the
conversation with more than a few people
who will go
i don't really like david moffat's
writing
but i did really like peter capaldi in
the part
so i feel like there's been an ability
to at least slightly decouple
the actor playing the doctor from the
showrunner of the time
with the other doctors of the modern era
that for some reason isn't happening
and hasn't with whitaker and chibnall
there's been a lot more close
association and conversations about them
almost
always happen together when people talk
about
one when people would speculate what one
leaving they'd also speculate the other
leaving at the same time again did turn
out to be true
but it is just odd to me that the two
just in
fan conversation have been linked
together almost as if they are one
person
uh to a degree that strikes me as
slightly odd
now again to be fair even within
chibnell's own admission the two of them
basically made an agreement
when they started that they were going
to just stick together and do it
uh the same amount of time for both so
maybe it was a more direct linking
uh and collab in terms of the
collaborative process developing of the
character i
i don't know neither does anyone else
other than the people who made the thing
but i would be lying if i didn't say i'm
a little relieved that
chibnall is leaving i am also a little
at this
moment a little disappointed that um
whitaker is leaving i didn't really
necessarily know how to feel all that
much
at the time it was announced that
capaldi was going to leave
because it was series 10 that made me
truly deeply fall in love
with his portrayal and at the time he
announced his departure that hadn't
aired yet
so i'm going into a situation where i
how i'm going to feel about whether this
was the right time for
whitaker to leave is going to depend a
lot on
a series that hasn't aired yet so by the
time that's done i may find myself going
ah i wish we could get one more series
with her under a different showrunner
um and i or i may not i may feel like
you know this is this is a good time to
exit but
with her i don't know with chipnel i
actually
i feel a little bit relieved um on
multiple fronts
actually because on the one hand unless
like something totally
out of left field happens for series 13
it's my
assumption and i've said this in a few
places that series 13
is going to have to deal with the
timeless child or
throwing it out there if series 13
doesn't the specials absolutely are
going to have to
so what i feel about chipnoll leaving is
okay he's going to finish out
the story he came in to tell and
honestly i'm glad for him for that
especially at this point because look
hypothetically
if as certain fans were
very loud to shout should have happened
if chibnall had been
fired at the end of series 12 or had
chosen to leave or whatever
that would have left us in a position
where clearly stuff was being set up
that is now either never going to be
addressed at all or is going to be
addressed by other people
and as much as i do not like
the timeless child reveal and i really
really don't
if he's going to do it and it's already
been done
i kind of want to see what story he
planned to weave out of having done that
and maybe by the time he's done i'll go
god that wasn't worth it at all
but at this point it was such a big
step and such a it was a
it was a bold take not one i agree with
but it was a bold take
um to do that that reveal and to do this
storyline that
i want to see where he's going with this
because
if you're going to move forward with
that much confidence i'm like
i'll see where you're going because you
seem to think it's worth what you've
done and
i'd like to see whether or not that
plays out
that having been said as uh as much as i
am happy that i do strongly believe that
he is going to be allowed to wrap up
that story
i'm also kind of glad he's leaving after
that and actually the fact that he's
announced his departure makes me feel
more confident
that he is going to wrap up the timeless
child story because
um if he doesn't have to worry about
keeping on
either the fan or the bbc's uh or the
production team's good sides
for futures past that he can just do the
story he wants to do
and not necessarily have to worry about
keeping everybody happy because oh my
god what if they don't take me back next
year
i mean there's a certain amount of
freedom in knowing you're not staying
and you can do the thing you want to do
again whether
me or you or anybody is happy with what
that ends up being
we'll see but i do appreciate that he's
going to have the chance to do that
again that said i'm kind of glad he's
leaving i have not
been an especially big fan of
well the writing under him and
most of the weakest scripts were written
not only
under his tenure but by him
so i'm not exactly bemoaning the loss
of chibnall to be fair i wasn't really
bemoaning the loss of
moffatt either by the time it happened
because it really did feel like he had
kind of
burned through whatever it was that uh
he had you know his his idea piled it
seemed like it was starting to run empty
by the time he was done so i wasn't
really bemoaning that either but it's
it's worth comparing because with
chippenhall it's a shorter amount of
time and i'm like okay look finish out
your story and let's
move on to something else there are lots
of other things that i do like about the
monitor i think it's
looked fantastic i think the the
way that the more recent series have
been shot and filmed has been
gorgeous and really looked great
and i hope that they can keep that sort
of thing going
another thing worth noting timeline wise
in all this is that it does mean
both whitaker and chippenal will be gone
prior to
the 60th anniversary now there's been a
presumption that there will be some kind
of big special because well
there was for the 50th um and doctor who
tends to like to mark its anniverse its
bigger anniversaries in some way if the
show is capable of doing so
so however that happens is going to
happen under
a new show runner and a new doctor so
if i were to guess what would probably
be the ideal
we'll see if this ends up happening
between budgets
you know and and whatever else goes on
if the world hasn't completely burned
down yet
i expect that the ideal would be
for the uh new doctor a new showrunner
to have
a complete series in 2023
during the year and ahead of some kind
of 60th special in
november of 2023 that would be my
hope and assumption for what everyone
involved would like to do
whether or not everything falls in line
for it to go down that way
i don't know but it certainly would not
be a great thing if uh 60th anniversary
happens that that ends up being the
introduction to a new doctor because
it would go much much better if we could
get to know whoever the new doctor is
going to be
and have some investment in them before
they're part of a celebration that
historically involves a bunch of other
doctors as well so we shouldn't be
trying to get to know a new doctor at
the same time they're bringing in old
ones
but again something that we don't know
what will happen
but timeline wise all of that will be
post
whitaker and post chibnall um but like i
said i'm not
gonna get into speculation on
the next start the next doctor as far as
performer goes partly because i'm gonna
be addressing that at least somewhat
in the video coming out on saturday
where i'm going to talk about
the possibilities likelihood and
arguments for or against
the next doctor being joe martin so
come on back for saturday for that as
far as a new show runner
i honestly don't know uh my go-to
pull would be toby whitehouse who has
done work on doctor who before
pretty good work in my own uh personal
opinion
and has also been a showrunner for other
shows before he did being human which is
not a show i
love but it's also a show that is
in terms of balancing you know bizarre
fantasy elements
and drama is not a million miles away
from doctor who
so if i had the power to pick the next
show runner
he's probably going to be my own
personal pick
unless you're gonna go absolutely
bonkers and uh name something like
charlie booker or neil gaiman like no no
and none of that stuff's gonna happen
but i think realistically uh toby
woodhouse would be
a very solid choice will it be him
i don't know there is the distinct
possibility that
you know we could have a showrunner who
doesn't have a direct history with the
modern era of doctor who
because that's been the way show runner
replacements have been so
far both moffett and chibnall wrote
for previous show runners and wrote
episodes in
earlier series prior to them taking over
so that's the
pattern that's a reasonable thing to
sort of think and sort of filter your
thinking through in terms of
who could be next they don't actually
necessarily have to do that now that's
not to say they bring in someone who
knows nothing about doctor who like you
can
get a you can get someone who's
knowledgeable as a fan who has not
worked in the series directly up to this
point that's
perfectly viable but
yeah it's going to be crazy times
in doctor who fandom for a while as
speculation runs rampant
about next showrunner and especially
about who the next doctor is going to be
but seriously
folks you're not going to find out till
towards the end of this year
at best but
that's where we stand chibnall's out
whitaker's out i hope
now even more than i was before for the
best
for their final run of episodes because
knowing that they're leaving i would
like them to finish strong
i would really like i would like that
for me as a fan and i would like that
for them as creators
but we're gonna have to wait and see as
we so
often do what are your thoughts on
all of this or anything that i've
brought up whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it be
polite it's fine to be happy if they're
leaving you don't have to like either of
these creators
but do not be rude and do not make
direct
personal attacks to either me them or
anyone else in the comments
i have been dealing with some nonsense
lately i
will swing the ban hammer but if you can
keep it polite
you don't have to agree with me i still
want to hear what you have to say i've
also got a patreon
which is how you can support me even
further there's also youtube memberships
there
are rewards available in both of those
formats for every tier of support
but um you also don't have to i mean the
likes to share subscribe so
those help me too but um i'm not going
to tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you are
the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
bye